you know there was a time not very long
ago when women's cosmetic and Beauty
Brands would cater very specifically to
women they would arguably go over the
top in that regard every ad you know was
about how special and wonderful and
unique and beautiful all women are just
the way they are which always did raise
questions as to why they would need the
products in the first place if they're
already special and and beautiful just
the way they are but the brands were
they were pandering and they were
pandering in a way that made sense to
the customer base that they were trying
to reach that all started to change a
few years ago first was the announcement
of the first dude Cover Girl James
Charles in 2016 and this prompted a sort
of nuclear arms race of wokeness uh with
other women's Brands rushing to find and
feature their own cross-dressers doesn't
make a lot of sense from a practical or
business standpoint
these companies are still predominantly
selling to females I mean really only
selling to females and the point of a
model for a fashion or cosmetic brand is
to demonstrate what the product looks
like the female customers want to know
what the product looks like on a woman
not on a drag queen but the race was on
in any case other Beauty Brands jumped
in last year Revlon tweeted a picture of
a guy named David Lopez bearded yet
caked in makeup with this caption
can we talk about how beautiful David
Lopez's look is it's all in the in the
details ColorStay concealer candid glow
Foundation ColorStay satin ink in your
go to
001
and eyes on you 006 I don't know what
the most of those words mean but I do
know what beautiful means and I know
that this picture ain't it
David Lopez's look could better be
described as ridiculous grotesque ugly
it appeals to almost no one on the
planet
see the walk left they applaud this
stuff in principle but few of them
actually find it attractive
because it's not about being attractive
or beautiful anyway
the fashion news site nylon profile
Lopez a few months ago and applauded him
for quote demystifying and degenderizing
the beauty space yes degenderizing
that may be one of the more annoying
fake words we've heard in recent years
but the greater point is that this is a
campaign to take femininity away from
women to degenderize it the point was
driven home a few days ago with the
launch of a new Pond hosted by ult which
is the beauty brand that owns hundreds
of salons all over the country in an
episode titled the beauty of girlhood
posted to Ulta Beauty's Twitter page the
degenderizing David Lopez interviews
quote unquote Tran
big scare quotes around that Dylan
Mulvaney now you may recognize that name
because Mulvaney has been all over the
place recently the media's latest and
greatest trans mascot most recently we
talked about he was a featured speaker
at the Forbes Women's Summit
when he came to prominence due to a
Tick-Tock series called days of girlhood
which documents his quote transition
from man to girl not man to woman you
may note but man to girl specifically he
identifies this is a grown man who
identifies not just as a woman but as a
girl
this transition as the videos uh
document on his Tick Tock page mostly
consists of him prancing around while
doing an exaggerated over-the-top
impression of femininity you may recall
this particularly degrading example here
it is again
day 66 being a girl and today I'm in
nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them
Bridges love them
coconut water love it not mad just love
it
wind turbine love it Meadows love them
did you see
let's see I'm scared of getting Lyme
disease
[Music]
you know I've been hiking in the woods
with my wife many times she does not
wear high heels and spandex for the
occasion in fact she wouldn't wear that
combination for any occasion least of
all a stroll through nature that's
because my wife is an actual woman
like a real one Dylan Mulvaney has
transition not into a woman but into a
cartoon and yet corporate brands in the
media have made him into a spokesman for
Womanhood which leads to this podcast in
which two males discuss the beauty of
girlhood and that is where this is said
listen
now I know I can find love I know I can
still be a performer I know that I can
have a family I want to be a mom one day
and I absolutely can and that's why the
narrative still has a long way to go
because when I was grieving boy Dylan I
didn't know those things were even
accessible to me
a mom one day he says that's that's all
it takes you know put on some lipstick
and uh stick a red bow in your hair and
suddenly the rules of biology no longer
obtain
you could be a mom
or soaky things
yeah and unfortunately for Dylan if he
ever wakes up to find his belly
distended it's not going to be a human
child in there it might be you know
maybe he contracted a parasite from some
bad Sushi or else maybe he's about to
reenact that scene from Alien but
whatever condition afflicts him he we
can be sure that the maternal experience
will always elude his grasp does it make
sense that the same company who controls
half of online retail also passively
eavesdrops on your private conversations
at home or that a single company
controls 90 of internet searches runs
your email service and gets to track
everything you do on your smartphone big
Tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and big Tech and
that's why I use expressvpn think about
how much of your life is on the internet
sadly every site you visit every video
you watch every message you send gets
tracked and data mined but when you run
expressvpn on your device the software
hides your IP address something big Tech
can use to personally identify you so
expressvpn makes your activity harder to
trace and harder to sell to advertisers
giving you privacy that you have a right
to expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
internet data to save to keep you safe
from hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network what I like most about
expressvpn is how easy it is to use just
download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and you're
protect it as simple as that and
expressvpn does all this without slowing
your connection that's why it's rated
the number one VPN service by techradar
The Verge and countless others so stop
handing over your personal data to the
big Tech Monopoly who Minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself with VPN I trust to
keep me safe online visit expressvpn.com
Matt walshow to get three extra months
for free expressvpn.com Matt walshow
expressvpn.com
now this discussion about girlhood
continues for almost an hour with two
men again discussing the beauty of
girlhood not Womanhood girlhood I'm not
going to subject you to much more of it
but I did find this portion interesting
where the two men give their thoughts
about the nature and definition of
beauty listen
the beauty really is it's the potential
I don't think Beauty for me is like an
end goal or like a one thing you know a
one look or a one specific moment it's
it's the ever-changing potential to
see myself in a light that makes me
really happy yeah that's so special and
I mean it's one of the many reasons I
love you and adore you and what you do
and
um why people I think relate to you
because there's this idea and this
concept that we as queer people we are
the stewards of change of this new world
because we are willing to live our life
joyfully through adversity and willing
to love ourselves
despite the world telling us we
shouldn't
you know there are certainly many
criticisms we can level against these
two but we cannot accuse them of having
a low self-image that's one thing we
can't say that is not a problem often
evident on the LGBT left where they tend
to carry around such massive and Hefty
egos that you wonder how they manage to
walk upright or fit through door frames
we note as always that the self is put
at the center here Dylan defines Beauty
as the ever-changing potential to see
myself in a light that makes me happy
now that's wordier than it needs to be
these people are allergic to speaking
clearly but the point is that beauty is
simply whatever good
because also whatever makes him feel
good Womanhood is whatever makes him
feel really all of every part of life is
defined by its ability to make him feel
good about him
everything really has the same
definition
and no definition at all at the same
time
this is not just nonsense but incredibly
demeaning and defensive
there is no substantive difference
between this
and a brand a white guy in the face to
Market to black people
and the end the more outrageous when you
consider that Mulvaney just quote became
a or a girl sorry a few months ago as a
tick tock stunt
now he he claims the title for himself
but even deems himself to speak for
women
he hasn't experienced any of the things
that women unique experience he hasn't
the challenges that women uniquely
encounter he hasn't paid the people that
women have to be
he can't relate to be a woman he has
absolutely no sight to offer on the
subject he puts on a Minstrel
we're expected to act like it's the real
deal
s
a great many people seem to be tired
finally of pretending
of playing
I've been waiting for the moment when
the society gets of this garbage
nonsense that we all always recognized
as nonsense
finally it seems like lots of people
don't want to play along anymore the
reaction Ulta beauty campaign has been
almost uniformly negative the able to
comments on YouTube and on Twitter
because almost every comment was
critical
particular speaking and now a boycott
movement is growing
I myself have been born to Beauty since
the day I was born but the hope is that
action customers will follow and refuse
to give their business to a company that
advertise to them buying and demeaning
them
this should be a a really a really
decision
you know there's like just the reason
why you should give this company ever
again in a just World Ultra Beauty be
bankrupted Android by next month
which is what needs to happen
you know it's one thing to be scared of
the appropriation and degradation of
Womanhood
but now the people respectful for it
need to feel the consequences
that's the only way I think all of this
stop finally
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block be there if not see you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]